el hobbit 19 se mueve con volatilidad en
brasil aunque el país es de lejos el más
afectado por la pandemia en américa
latina' investigadores del imperial
college de londres calcularon que la
tasa de transmisión del virus en agosto
fue menor a 1 el nivel necesario para
controlar el virus esta información se
dio a conocer justo cuando el país cerró
una semana la baja en el número de
fallecidos
la semana pasada por primera vez el
promedio de muertes fue de menos de 1000
por un día una estadística celebrada por
políticos cuya estrategia es promover
una mayor flexibilidad en lo económico y
lo social
y sociales pero aunque estos datos han
sido interpretados por el gobierno como
una señal para la reapertura económica
que ya se ha venido reactivando en el
país en los últimos días las cifras
repuntaron y los expertos advierten que
es demasiado pronto para pensar que lo
peor ya pasó
es un momento muy delicado para nuestro
país y de mucha preocupación para la
cruz roja porque tenemos que hacerle
entender al gobierno que la economía y
la salud es importante las personas que
están trabajando se están contagiando en
todas pero la narrativa del presidente a
yair wesson harto de desvirtuar la
pandemia parece ir ganando terreno la
vida nocturna y los días de playa
volvieron a llenar las calles de las
principales ciudades brasileñas
en brasil todo está desorganizado si
esto continúa todo será peor varios
expertos coinciden en que si se hubieran
tomado medidas a tiempo brasil no habría
tenido que llorar tantas víctimas y todo
parece indicar que la cuenta no va a
parar